yo dawg i heard you like exclusive hey
what is up guys I'm Kim PhD here and we
just got that brand new red iPhone now
we have a new matte black one plus three
T so I've said it before and I'll say it
again matte black all of the things so
one plus a couple days ago announced a
Collette version of their one plus three
T the latest on a collaboration which
meant they would only be making 250 of
them and you could only buy it if you
either live in or fly to Paris because
they're only selling it in this one
Colette pop-up store there basically it
wasn't even for sale for most people but
I think one plus here is the matte black
hypetrain
loud and clear because now they're doing
a full-on production run of this what
they're calling midnight black one plus
three T it's this all matte black phone
it's essentially what Apple did with the
iPhone 7 a refresh of the exact same
product with a new coat of paint so this
one you used to have just gunmetal and
gold as a color choices now you can
choose gunmetal gold or this black and
that gunmetal was just a little bit
darker than the silver from the 1+3 of
earlier last year but now you can see
with them all lined up that they really
went all out with the matte black this
time I'd say pretty much on par with the
matte black iPhone the matte black is
actually slightly less photogenic than
the red but in a good way it's way more
stealthy and that is why I've liked
matte black text so much now obviously
you're looking at one of the super rare
Colette Edition one plus three T's here
which has the sickest box by the way all
red and black with the blue sleeve
around it but the midnight black one
plus three T that's going to be
available for everyone to buy is exactly
the same - the Colette logo that's it so
if you can imagine that just without the
logo there you have it midnight black
one plus three T other things going to
be available at March 28th and
apparently for again a limited time
unlike the iPhone but they're going to
make way more than 250 of them so it
should be able to be picked up if you
want one not sure exactly how much that
means are going to make but everything
else again about the phone is exactly
the same as the standard color brother
same specs same storage same hundred
twenty eight gigs with six gigs of ram
same cameras same speakers same
accessories and
same price 479 bucks but something you
should know is this phone is also right
next up in line for Android 7.1.1 update
that is pretty much rolling out as I
speak
it's funny the first phone to get
Android 7.1.1 that's not a nexus or a
pixel of any kind was the ZTE axon 7
curiously enough and then the second one
is this phone the 3t so I guess this
phone is aging pretty well so far aside
from just the new color I think it
should continue to get patches and
updates since oxygen OS is so
lightweight now some may see this as
like a cheap easy way to take advantage
of a refresh news cycle you know
rerelease the same exact product fresh
coat of paint whatever no big deal but
let me tell you why I'm happy that they
went with matte black and why everyone
should get on the matte black train the
absolute best technology and I think the
ones that just work and that no one has
to really worry about it just melts away
and is sort of in the background like
this Asus monitor for example is my
favorite I've ever used not because it's
beautiful or anything but because I can
completely ignore it when using the
software on it
I actually replace the LG 5k back with
this guy for this exact reason it will
be even better without the logos on the
front of it but there's a reason why you
pretty much never see TV bezels that are
white they're always dark my favorites
looking foam when given a choice are
pretty much always the least shiny and
least fancy looking and always the ones
with the darker bezels for these little
things like watching a video with black
bezels is less distracting than white
bezels and with the super thin bezels
we've been seeing in 2017 if you're
going to go with thin bezels you might
as well make them black instead of
defeating the purpose and making them
like gold or white or something so the
most undercover stealthy low-profile
look for any tech product is matte black
so all aboard the matte black hype train
and I'm happy they went with matte black
with one plus 3t now if you want to win
one of the Colet edition super limited
edition one of 250 phones I will be
giving one of these away pretty soon and
it's going to be over on Instagram so
I'll link that below the like button if
you want to get down on that be sure to
follow over there that's going to be
happening sometime pretty soon from one
is uploaded but that's pretty much it so
this is everything you need to know
about the midnight black one plus 3t
thank you for watching talk to you guys
in
one piece